- [Kelly] Is this true,
- [Sarah] Yeah.
- that you and Princess Di
once dressed as policewomen?
Like for a, was it a bachelorette party?
- That was my hen party actually, 1986.
- [Kelly] Okay, oh is that what
you call them, hen parties?
- [Sarah] Yes.
- [Kelly] I love that, I didn't know that.
- [Sarah] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- [Kelly] I love this, so.
- But you know, we were,
it was extraordinary, because
we went to a nightclub.
Of course you go to a nightclub
with the Princess of Wales,
then Princess of Wales.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I was just still Fergie,
wasn't married yet, and,
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- and we went into this
nightclub and she was in,
she was very good, as her costume.
Anyway, so we sat down
and the waiter came up to us and said,
"Excuse me, this is a member's
club and it's for fun.
And we don't serve police officers here."
Looking straight at us.
- They thought you were
real police officers, A.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- And then two,
they kicked police officers out?
- [Sarah] Yes, yes.
And we went out and as we came
out of the, up the stairs,
a lady was getting out
of a cab and Diana said,
"She's got my dress on!"
I said, "Dutch!"
I called her Dutch.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
I said, "Dutch no!
No, no you can't say that.
We're meant to be police officers."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was very funny and then we were -
- Keep in character!
- But Kelly, we were then arrested.
- I missed this story, what?
- We were arrested by Parks police, right?
So we got in the back of the van.
- What, what did you do to get arrested?
- And she had put her engagement
ring 'round the other way.
And I'd put mine 'round the other way.
And we were sitting in there like this
and she just looked around
and saw a smokey bacon flavored crisp
and started taking them and eating them.
- Okay.
- And the policeman in the front said,
"You can't do that!"
We were completely -
- Just did.
- [Kelly] Just did.
- Yeah, yeah and then
eventually they realized
that it was, you know, Diana.
- [Kelly] But, but -
- And me.
- But, but, wait!
Why did y'all get arrested?
- Oh, because we were
impersonating police officers.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- But it was so funny.
- [Kelly] People are allowed
to be in costume.
- Hello?
- Yeah.
- Anyway, but even so -
- Ah, hello.
- I mean, do you, yeah.
- I love you.
- [Sarah] So funny.
- That's incredible.
- [Sarah] Incredible.
- Oh my God.
- And of course, everyone
always says to me,
"But you must miss Dutch, you and Diana."
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I go,
"No, 'cause I laugh.
I mean, I'm with her,
she's with me all day."
I just, 'cause she's
the only one who really,
she and I, we laughed a lot.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- We got into trouble a lot.
And then she used to do, you
know what she used to do?
She used to tell me the
worst story, joke story,
just before I had to be serious.
So I'd go straight in to dinner and I'd,
and she'd always, 'cause she'd been there
a few years before me.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- She used to run like a gazelle
to get into the dining
room quicker than me.
And I now, I thought,
"Well that's a bit strange."
And when I got in, I realized why,
'cause she got the young people
and I got all the old people.
- [Kelly] She, a clever one.
- [Sarah] Mhm.